une inauguration en grande pompe la
ministre des sports laura flessel s'est
rendu ce mercredi 30 mai au sporting de
bouygues
l'occasion pour l'ancien sportif de haut
niveau de découvrir le nouveau visage de
la structure entièrement rénové pour
plusieurs millions d'euros ça donne
envie
mais aujourd'hui j'ai quand même des
talons donc du coup j'éviterai d'enfer
mais c'est vrai que ça donne envie et
puis derrière ce qui est bien aussi
c'est que c'est ouvert aussi au public
donc ça permet aussi de valoriser la
pratique pour tous le lifting comprend
notamment la rénovation des courts de
tennis des terrains de squash chez des
vestiaires une zone d'équipements de
golf a également été créé une vraie
demande de la part des 2500
collaborateurs qui viennent sur le site
quotidiennement et qui trouvait l'ancien
sporting vieillissant après 30 ans
d'existence dans le cadre notamment
d'une insulte à la mode la qualité de
vie au travail
il est important que nos collaborateurs
puissent bénéficier d'interventions de
ce type
afin dé effectivement venir faire du
sport le midi le soir pour toute
tranquillité avec des installations
dignes de ce nom
en parallèle de la venue de la ministre
bouygues construction a profité pour
signer un partenariat avec la fédération
hde handigolf objectifs permet de créer
une école de golf en faveur des
personnes handicapées
le site a également acheté une machine
pour permettre aux pratiquants de taper
la petite balle blanche